all right so uh soncho 3 the first thing
is um don't fetishize the
form uh you want to in another you
instead you want to connect the form to
the truth and to the way don't reverse
that
um there's been a lot of crazy stuff
with cha sensei's weapons in my opinion
it's just my
opinion and and um there's like a big
telephone game like you know this person
showed it to that person so there's lots
of variation and that is Complicated by
the fact that Sensei was these a lot of
this stuff was Works in progress so if
you were introduced to it at one point
in its development you learned one way
and if you were introduced to it later
in its development you learned another
way okay so more reason not to go this
is what I was shown this is what the
form is keep it a living form all right
so the set revolves around ban versus
Joe and so there's certain fighting
principles because there's a physical
component to everything we're training
in and then there are certain energetic
components and those things help us
develop the spiritual components so the
physical components are some of the
things you're going to do is take
advantage of how much faster the sword
is to the Joe if you're in a particular
M so you're trying to get into that M
and then capitalize upon another
advantage that the sword has over the
Joe and that is that it is a blade and
not a stick okay so you'll follow a lot
of the fighting principles related to
blade for example there's a lot of
defanging the snake in s show 3 and
that's what you're trying to do if this
person is going going to uh stick his
hand in the middle of the fight which he
has to do to wield his longer weapon
then I'm going to cut his hand off that
is defanging the snake Okay that will
require less penetration of me which is
one of the advantages that the Joe has
over is the Joe can penetrate but at a
distance all right but there is a um
limit to how you play this m so there's
a particular M that this works and if
you close too much then the reverse side
of the Joe becomes relevant and is quite
potent as well so a lot of the set is
where do I hang out so I can defang the
snake and then the joe side a lot of
this set is how do I got get not get
deaged and bring this person into my
range um of what I need to do okay and
when it does that the way to take away
the blade advantage over the stick
Advantage is what you always do is
you're going to cut off all cuts at its
source that's what you're going to do
okay generally speaking so here we go
with the first
set my son does not know the set so I'll
be teaching him as a reviewing it for
those who do know it okay you don't
start at any kind of seon because you
got to obey that rule that he has what's
ideal for him so stand where you would
be ideal with your job if you were going
to ski me okay about that distance right
well I don't want to stand here because
that Advantage goes to him so I'm kind
of out further right and what I want to
try to do because I have the shorter uh
bladed weapon is I want him to stick his
weapon in the middle of the fight so
that I can clip his arm off okay and
real fencing if you clip this part off
the fight is over okay um so that is a
very realistic strategy so let's Scoot a
little this
way okay so first thing is where's that
my where I'm not in Joe Advantage range
okay so for example if we were doing
like a some weird seon put your Joe out
in the middle you see no but hold it
like you were going to fight with it no
pleas hold it normally please hold the
Joe normally stay there but stick the
weapon out here do you guys see this and
you were here because the length of his
weapon he has greater Advantage here so
we're not in any kind of seon and we're
not in Joe Advantage we're outside of
Joe Advantage when we line up here okay
and I have my Blade with no opening and
he has his weap weon guarding his Center
Line with no opening ready to go okay no
one can hit each other so that's the
first thing so scoop back so the first
thing is you set up that dilemma where
we're
here here this is too close and
obviously this was not set up any
motivation in him to strike so that I
could counter he would move forward so
this isn't hit either so we do it again
out and you come up and you learn where
I'm just out of Joe range okay all right
let's try that go all right so I want to
give you a metric on where is that space
eventually as you train uh with
intensity as we've showed you there's an
intensive variation of Keon which does
not use the embryonic timings okay uh So
eventually you'll learn where that is
cuz this guy keeps spearing the hell out
of you right so you're you're not in a
St there please you're not in normal
seon which you might think between the
two Joe's uh because my weapon is
shorter so I don't want to give that
Advantage okay so if you were to do
normal
ski and you would see that
easily he would I'm in his Advantage
range okay so we scoop back and so when
you get to that position you don't want
to be way out here because you do not
generate the intensity which is going to
generate his movement which is going to
allow me to counter his movement which
is how you rock a shorter weapon um from
out here there's no charge there that
would motivate him and I'll get there in
a second so I want to be in a place
where if he does a normal ski go ahead
I'm just right outside of it do you see
that that is is where I want to be okay
so he can't he's not going to penetrate
me from there without violation form but
there's no energy in that so there's his
good ski that's where I want to be and I
want to know that
intuitively eventually as I've trained a
lot of people they're kind of like way
here and then they're like here this is
not the same this is where you where you
want to be without him having thrown the
Joe okay so that is where go back now
that is where this form begins from
there okay all right let's try it again
okay uh generally if you're going to
watch this and you're going to want to
refine your form the most
common mistake I see is that the m is
always too short it's always too close
Okay it comes from we just ftiz the form
and we just touch sticks but the May is
wrong okay so people are Too Close um so
what I'm trying to do in the form with
this beginning m is uh ultimately bait
this guy all right but let's look at it
tactically a little bit his weapon has
to attack from the bottom up it cannot
attack from the top down because of how
he's using it defensively right now so
there's two things that you can do here
is one you can go from chudan to jodon
because if he's going to attack it's
going to come from the bottom do do you
guys see that so he could let's move
around from that ceiling he could spin
it around in other words spin around
yourself just go around it's fine but me
you want to
hit do you get it so it's going around
come on just bring it around don't give
a crap how do you see that he could then
it came from the top down but he's given
major opening as he goes there okay so
no not to not true if he wants to attack
for example ski the tip Came From The
Bottom upward do you guys see that okay
so to do that if you're here in your
little scalemate you could go dude I
know he's got to come from the top from
the bottom so I can take jodon and my
counter is going to be that much more
effective because I can hit him as he's
coming up okay or your reasoning for
this is going to be that he's going to
fill the y space so as my weapon goes up
he fills that space okay so we'll
demonstrate that
now so it's it's very subtle because
both happen so I'll talk us through it
again my son does not know the form okay
so he's in Chon
level and he's just out of my ski range
okay my weapon has to attack from the
bottom he notices that so he's going to
go to
jodon got it okay but I'm going to
counter his seeking of advantage by
following his weapon in don't move don't
worry okay and now I'm going to occupy
the center line This movement that
you're doing here you do it all the time
in sh manucci so for example look at our
shui EO videos the hand goes up and we
catch their weapon on the way up we
don't wait for it to come down okay so
if I stay here he goes up I just lost
all Advantage I've lost all Advantage
cuz my weapon has to come from there uh
I would probably move out and try
dancing around this kind of thing cuz I
lost all Advantage so that's what he is
trying to do gain Advantage go back and
my first counter is as he tries to gain
Advantage I fill that Advantage up do
you see because I'm working with him and
I now dominate the center line his face
should be out of range if we had the
right mind okay but but I still want the
center line so again we're here and as
he goes up I come in and attack the
center line now his sword has to come
down somewhere to attack right and do
shui and here's go just slow just go
there you go cool let's do it again but
I now have control of this hands boom
like we always do okay so again first
move chew on point it up no point it at
the throat okay up more at the throat so
again the first thing set up the proper
mind he goes all right let me seek
Advantage by going to jodon and I regain
Advantage by controlling the center line
okay it's up here like that so again
making this incorrect
go wrong too late or
he goes
up wrong there's no Advantage there
that's exactly what he wanted do get it
he just come down and smash it so again
as he goes up he pulls me in boom and
right as his fist lower it reverse the
action reverse it reverse it right as
his fist pass his
head my weapon is there that's the right
timing okay so I have to be able to read
his b body he goes and I'm in like that
okay that is the first move go uh it
seems like a small thing but this that
first my establishing that is huge okay
uh just like because it's KN fighting
it's KN fighting and my is everything
okay you live or die by whether you
follow my or you violate my okay so um
it shouldn't be
a strike it's not a strike if he could
strike me because I was too close so for
example we're here do you get it and I
go like this and he does that move and
he'd hit me in the face put your hand
where it goes okay I was too close he
didn't need to wait for an opening he
could just uh Mia T my hand boom and
then ski like we always do do you got it
we'll do it again cuz I want you to
figure it out boom and in do you get it
so I was out of race all he's doing is
retaking the advantage by taking and
holding the center
line if you look at it we're back in Joe
rage do you see that's what he was able
to do cuz he's at the tip of his weapon
and he has the advantage cuz I can't
reach him and he can reach me so he has
the advantage okay um but as he's in
that last position get in that position
where you retake the center
line it's got to be legit so a lot of
people want to make it a strike and they
throw this stuff out there like that do
you see they're trying to get extra
range on the face okay but in real in
real fight and then I just grab the damn
thing and now thank
you okay so you your weapon has to be
under your control you cannot sit there
and poke that out because in real
fighting and it should be real fighting
you have the right my so that I don't
use my personal weapons do do you guys
get that you have to have that m in the
set so that I don't sidekick you or
roundhouse kick you or grapple you that
you have to stay in the weapon range
okay uh and that means you have to be
organized for that kind of stuff so
let's trade rolles
here
you you can put that down just put it
down and so when I'm in this position
here and he goes to grab the weapon I
should be able he should feel my weight
do you see and you you have all of your
uh Jo so that means you have all of your
adhesions that you can do and your cooku
projections and none of that is out here
like this okay none of it is here either
so when I'm here like this this and he
just push don't hurt me but just push it
backwards you see and I'm going to lose
control of it so here if he pushes on it
he just hits my grounding vectors do you
see and with those grounding vectors
that's where I can project him out so I
don't know if you caught the UK but some
people can see that if I'm over here
there's no uh structural Integrity to it
and if he just grabs it and shoves it
down now I'm in trouble but if I'm here
like this and he grabs it and he tries
to push I'm ground vectoring which of
course I can project out and you can get
your distance again which is your
advantage here
okay and we'll stop there those seem
like simple moves but I'm telling you
everyone I've seen gets them wrong okay
and they set everything else up and the
only reason it appears to work is these
people stop fighting and they just
started touching sticks so we'll stop
with those two moves first move is
establish the generating tension M which
I gave you a metric you should be just
out of ski range okay and then seek
advantage and then counter the seeking
of Advantage by regaining the center
line so it's really three things you're
working on there